what is the first relationship you like  to reset as president call the European  leaders and say we're back first country  I would go to would be China Street  China we need to cooperate with them on  climate change we have no idea which of  our most important allies he will have  pissed off worse between now and then  what we know is that our relationship  with the entire world needs to change  NATO will fall apart if he's elected  four more years I think it is rebuilding  trust in the United Nations all the  members of the NATO to engage in Ron to  stabilize the Middle East every  latin-american country that's willing to  have a conversation we're breaking up  with Russia and making up with NATO  thank you all thank you all we have ones  with good